after the mysterious suicide of a nun at
the Karla monastery priest Father Burke
a new practice and nun sister Irene are
sent to investigate arriving at the
monastery the two discovers some
unorthodox things about the worshippers
there that hint at the fact that all is
not what it seems none of the brothers
or sisters appear to be upset by the
suicide and reassured the duo that she
now serves at the hand of the master
this startles the pair as Catholics tend
to believe that suicide is a mortal sin
and one that dooms a person who commits
it to hell they learned from a
mysterious man named the Duke who is the
deceased nuns father that his daughter
will someday rule with the power beyond
mortals other strange things about the
location are the fact that the
worshippers all practice from a
non-standard prayer book and carry a
strange device with them at all times in
addition to this there's also a strange
nun that stalks sister Irene as she
delves deeper into her investigation and
it warns her the coming catastrophe
tensions heightened as Burke and Irene
learn that the villages next at the
monastery believed that it is in fact a
cult led by the Duke that practices are
summoning demons with the help of a
local man known as Frenchie the three
managed to steal the devices that the
initiates carry and discover that using
them they are able to control demons
using their new abilities they managed
to battle to the top of the monastery
where they discover the Duke performing
a ritual the Duke explains that God is
planning to punish humanity and that we
would be defenseless to stop him in
order to stand a chance he and his
followers have been attempting to summon
forth a warrior for mankind known as his
majesty
the nun who committed suicide had
succeeded in bringing forth Malik His
Majesty's most powerful servant and
phthalic has came here to set the stage
for the main act a fight ensues in which
the Duke is killed with a shotgun by
Frenchie and balance manifests and
betrays his majesty by stabbing her
master in the back
literally Dalek absorbs his powers and
becomes the none that we know and love
today left with no other choice the
surviving trio decide to make a Blood
Pact with Valek and this is because they
can no longer find salvation or
redemption from the church and are
fearful of God's vengeance joining with
the demon is the only choice that they
have and though it may cost them their
souls they will survive a prequel based
around a character that appears later in
the series was never going to have a
scene in which they would have feit it
but even so the nun still managed to
surprise me with its ending we will all
be tempted with evil at some point in
our lives and I enjoyed the fact that
the film managed to subvert my
expectations and have the heroes slowly
turned into the things that they hated
the most
this shows perhaps that their faith was
not as in shaking as they would believe
and the movie as a whole can be used as
a metaphor for temptation it's a smart
move to steep a film set in a monastery
as a metaphor for the Battle of good and
evil and I love watching the characters
become completely tempted by evil at the
film's close this highlights just how
strong the demon Ballack is and how she
was able to control people in the
conjuring series it's a nice twist that
doesn't ruin the films that preceded it
as prequels often do and I think the
film definitely is worth checking out if
you're a fan of the series so what did
you think of the nun how would you rank
it amongst the rest of the series and
what would you like to see next comment
below and let me know and if you enjoyed
this video then please like it and
subscribe to my channel I create content
like this weekly and they'll definitely
be something on here that you love if
you're a fan of film recently I
discussed the ending of Jack Ryan season
1 so make sure you check that video out
next linked at the end of this one again
thanks for taking the time to watch this
I've been definition you've been the
best and I'll see you next time take
care peace
you